we're going to start today with this
continued Fiasco involving the January 6
Trump Riot commission it is absolutely
stunning what is going on and what has
happened over the last 24 hours although
not all together surprising if you've
been following the Republican party for
the last several years so yesterday I
told you on the show
that
um a House minority leader Republican
Kevin McCarthy had selected five
Republicans to be on the new version of
the January 6th commission which will
investigate what the hell happened on
January 6th now remember this commission
is instead of the one that was proposed
originally months ago which Republicans
said absolutely no to and as I pointed
out yesterday at least two of the five
people selected by Kevin McCarthy
Congressman Jim Jordan and Congressman
Jim Banks are effectively
insurrectionists now what I mean by that
is they weren't saying go to the Capitol
right now on January 6th
but they were participants in the
ginning up of doubt about the election
results in the months leading up to
January 6th which had people so fired up
and almost like in a feverish state of
arousal where they just went to the
Capitol and did the riots and attempted
the Insurrection on January 6. so
effectively you were going to have
insiders investigating the Insurrection
that they incited now good for her
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
decided to Bar Jim Jordan and Jim Banks
from being on the commission and
considering that the only reason that
Jim Jordan and Jim Banks were going to
be there would be to derail the
investigation to distract from the
substance and to talk about other things
like the George Floyd protests of a year
before
or whatever the case may be I think it's
great that Nancy Pelosi did this now I
know there are people who are going to
say well Nancy Pelosi is terrible
whatever your opinion of Nancy Pelosi
this decision I agree with they were
putting Insiders on the panel to
investigate what they incited it's
absolutely crazy the Associated Press
reporting house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
rejected to Republicans selected by
Kevin McCarthy McCarthy said the
Republican Party won't participate in
the investigation if Democrats won't
accept the members he appointed
Pelosi cited the Integrity of the probe
in refusing to accept the appointments
of Jim Banks picked by McCarthy to be
the top Republican on the panel or Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan the two men are
outspoken allies of trump whose
supporters laid Siege to the capital
that day and interrupted the
certification of Joe Biden's win both of
them voted to overturn the election
results in the hours after The Siege not
a trivial detail Democrats have said the
investigation will go on either way
Pelosi said she spoke to McCarthy and
told him she would be rejecting the two
names okay good so what do Republicans
Now do
they again frame themselves as the
victims let's take a look at a press
conference that Kevin McCarthy did and
let's listen and then we will discuss
we will run our own investigation right
we have law enforcement
we have military we have doctors we have
people from all walks of life
they want to know the answer the
American people deserve that they don't
deserve politics they don't deserve
destroying the institution no Committee
in Congress will work
if one person is picking all who can
serve now of course it's not true that
one person is picking all who can serve
and it's not true that it is a a height
that it's exclusively a democratic
commission three of the five people that
Kevin McCarthy selected Nancy Pelosi has
no problem with Nancy Pelosi has also
selected a republican in Liz Cheney to
be on the committee so that it would be
bipartisan even with Kevin McCarthy
pulling everybody but Liz Cheney is the
wrong type of Republican and we'll get
back to Liz Cheney momentarily but the
most important thing to remember is that
the initial structure of this uh
investigation that was proposed months
ago was by definition bipartisan and
Republicans rejected it the initial
setup was going to be 10 members
uh Democrats choose five Republicans
choose five every the Democratic member
would be the chair a republican member
would be the vice chair and every
subpoena sent out to a witness would
have to be signed off on by both the
Democratic chair and the Republican Vice
chair Republicans rejected that entire
framework
um and we're going to get to here why
that was and the revisionist history
around that listen to this Mr leader
you're complaining that you don't have a
bipartisan opportunity here to
investigate January 6th but you stood in
the way of a bipartisan commission
that's right to be made up of
independent members right
yes you did uh your conference voted
against that uh at least a majority of
your conference voted against it and it
was blocked in the Senate why did you
not allow that to go forward listen to
this what you say you want is a
bipartisan investigation into what
happened on January 6th for the same
politics Pelosi played then at the same
time when she used the scope of that
remember how long it took
on January 13th Rodney Davis and myself
both requested
a 911 Commission
even those who ran the 911 Commission
criticized Nancy Pelosi for what she
wanted to do
we had officer Evans killed on Good
Friday but she said you couldn't look at
that
if you study the 911 Commission they
didn't study what happened on just
September 11th they studied what built
up to it but she said no you could not
do that now this is maybe the most
deceptive framing of what happened
understand that what Republicans wanted
to do when the commission was initially
discussed months ago Republicans said we
want to study the context but what was
the context Republicans wanted to study
Republicans wanted to include in a
January 6th commission the protests
during the summer of 2020 over police
brutality and the killing of George
Floyd that's what they wanted to make
the January 6 commission about which was
going to make it a complete and total
distraction Republicans wanted to
include in that January 6th commission
the killing of Steve I'm sorry the
shooting of Steve scalise in 2017 why
because they wanted to make the entire
thing about here are all these different
instances of people going too far but
mostly it's Democrats and people on the
left going too far nothing to do
whatsoever ever with the January 6
commission and the context that
Republicans wanted to include in the
January 6 commission was a defense of
the claim that the election was not
really won by Joe Biden why because if
Republicans in the January 6th
commission could make the case that the
rioters were right to be upset about the
election results because it really was
stolen by Joe Biden it would in a sense
justify their violent actions on January
6. and Nancy Pelosi rightly said we're
not going to do that that's what Kevin
McCarthy is talking about that Nancy
Pelosi rejected it's completely
dishonest and now I don't know what's
going to happen
McCarthy's saying they're just going to
do their own commission okay uh Liz
Cheney by the way I don't want to
rehabilitate Liz Cheney's image as I've
said before Liz Cheney's a horrible
Republican who voted with Trump like 90
of the time she just disagreed on this
one thing uh here is Liz Cheney saying
actually the two people Pelosi is not
allowing on the commission their
behavior was disgraceful she's right not
to do not to allow them uh there are
three members that the minority leader
proposed that the speaker did not object
to uh she is objected to two members and
the rhetoric around this from the
minority leader and from those two
members has been disgraceful so Liz
Cheney because of those comments being
called a republican in name only she's
not really a republican how can she say
that asked again she says I agree with
what Nancy Pelosi decided you dude you
personally did you personally urge the
speaker to take this step I
uh and then also asked about the
specifics of why she thinks these two
shouldn't be on the commission uh she
said the following at every opportunity
right
speaker objected to two Republican
members she accepted three others she
objected to two one of whom may well be
a material witness to events this is a
key thing
the Republicans want investigators who
are really more witnesses and
participants in what took place it led
to that day right led to January 6th the
other who disqualified himself by his
comments in particular over the last 24
hours demonstrating that he is not
taking this seriously so Liz Cheney is
on the same page as Nancy Pelosi Liz
Cheney is no great hero she's a
republican who agrees with Trump on just
about everything but on this issue she
is actually seemingly doing what she
believes is right so that's the latest
with the commission which is just
becoming a complete joke of a situation
thanks to Republicans let's now talk a
little bit about how Republicans are
reacting in the aftermath of this
commission falling apart from the
standpoint of it actually being
something Republicans will participate
in meaningfully one of our sponsors is
rise the science-based app that makes it
easy to improve your sleep and daily
energy I have struggled with sleep at
times in my life life I've tried many
different things and Rise has been
really useful it tracks your sleep debt
which is how much sleep you essentially
owe your body tracks your general
rhythms helps you understand your
daytime energy levels and Rise can
improve your sleep and energy by giving
you personalized feedback about your
sleep metrics when you should go to bed
when you should wake up in terms of
optimizing at your personal rest it can
even tell you things like how long
should you expect to be groggy in the
morning based on when you wake up you
can make science-based improvements to
16 different habits that will make you
feel more rested every day and most rise
users start feeling that way in the
first five days including me and Rise is
still helping me every day it's great
it's based on real sleep science very
few things are as important as improving
your sleep go to rise science.com Pacman
to try rise free for a week the link is
underneath this video